[Musica]
oggi sono qua oggi sono qua per parlare
del mio talento
ecco secondo me noi non lasciamo già con
l'etichetta col nostro talento non cosa
siamo bravi o diventeremo bravi a fare
ma il nostro talento lo scopriamo lungo
il nostro percorso con le sue esperienze
ascoltando le emozioni che proviamo
qua c'è una determinata cosa lo
scopriamo scoprì noi stessi e prima di
parlarvi del mio talento
voglio farvi conoscere un pezzo di me e
del mio percorso
il mio percorso è iniziato parecchi anni
fa poi non saranno ancora grandi
progetti grandi obiettivi ma c'era
soltanto un bambino con una grande
passione per tutto ciò che potesse
andare veloce fino bambino sono sempre
stato un sacco attratto da una velocità
dalle due alle quattro ruote e da
bambino caro cercavo di vivere il più
possibile con i mezzi che avevo a
disposizione come i modellini delle
macchinine moto delle auto e mi ricordo
che passava giornate intere a costruirsi
le piste dove dove farle correre
guardando le gare alla tv e anche spesso
andando a guardare le gare dal vivo nei
circuiti del della zona anche giocando i
videogiochi però quelli preferivo di
gran lunga la bici era il mio mezzo con
cui sfogare la mia voglia di velocità
per contro una bici potesse andare
veloce e nel cortile nelle strade
bianche nei boschi anche lasciando
spesso qualche pezzo di me sull'asfalto
e da quel momento avevo già capito che
la velocità serve è diventata la mia più
grande passione e la conferma arrivata
al sesto compleanno quando i miei
regalarono una vera e propria mini moto
e neanche dirlo con quella minimoto fu
subito amore anche se la vecchia perché
non sapeva nemmeno il parafango per poco
importava
da quel momento stare in sella era
diventata la cosa che più mi piaceva
fare e anche se
non so esattamente descrivervi cosa
provavo in quel momento però sentivo che
quella era la mia strada
la mia strada da seguire e così ho fatto
a 360 gradi non solo non di moto ma
anche iniziando a fare i primi lavoretti
sulla bici poi sui motorini sulla moto
poi mi era anche iscritto a una scuola
di meccanica dove pensavo di imparare di
più ma la cosa principale che più
importante che ho imparato è stata
condividere questa passione che mai
compagni di classe
però si sa ancora cosa principale era
sempre l'andare in moto dalla mini moto
sono passato dal 51 marcia 125 al 2 e
mezzo però era solo se volete solo
sfogavo questo ne voglia sony nei campi
e nei festini privati nel bosco fino a
quando a 15 anni volevo trasformare in
qualcosa di più
questo semplice divertirmi volevo
gareggiare allora così ormai con un team
locale su come fare per gareggiare ecco
non era proprio come torre nei campi per
gareggiare si gareggiava in pista e in
pista non c'ero mai andato ma 15 anni le
moto non era l'unica cosa che avevo in
testa c'era anche tutto il capitolo
ragazze amici le prime uscite prime
cavolate insomma 15 anni io me la stavo
vivendo una grande non stavo godendo tra
spassarmela in questo percorso del
bambino ragazzo che avrà con tutto
velocemente avevo messo insieme da dei
piccoli traguardi degli obiettivi da
raggiungere un pezzettino alla volta
come fossero un castello di carte ecco
il mio castello di carte a 15 anni per
me era bellissimo e indistruttibile però
un giorno quel castello di carte in un
attimo è crollato è crollato tutto il 22
giugno del 2010 di quel giorno io non mi
ricordo assolutamente nulla
mia mamma mi ha raccontato che la
chiamai dicendo che ero caduto
a rialzarmi lei chiama subito i soccorsi
che però tardarono ad arrivare perché io
ero di un campo a sua volta dentro un
bosco arrivarono dopo un'ora e mezza con
l'elisoccorso e mi trovarono in
condizione a dir poco disperate mi
portarono d'urgenza all'ospedale dove la
prognosi fu subito brutta perché avevo
rotto sei costole che mi perforarono un
polmone l'altro polmone collassato
un'emorragia interna non respiravo in
più mi ero mi era esplosa una vertebra
all'altezza di 5 a metà e metà dorso e
per questo venne operato d'urgenza per
stabilizzare la colonna con barre in
titanio lunga 30 centimetri che porto
che porta ancora dentro per poi mettermi
in coma farmacologico per per cinque
giorni
giunto il momento del risveglio avevo i
miei genitori li è la prima cosa di che
cosa fosse successo in quel momento loro
potevano dirmi qualsiasi cosa anche che
ero caduto dalle scale perché io avevo
il buio il buio totale non mi ricordavo
assolutamente assolutamente nulla
da quel momento la mia il mio cammino ha
preso una nuova strada una strada che
non avevo certo io maniera mi era stata
imposta però stava a me scegliere come
percorrerla insieme a alla strada era
cambiati anche i miei nuovi obiettivi il
primo è il più importante era quella di
riuscire a tornare a una vita normale
una volta stabilizzata e le mie
condizioni mi trasferirò a gervasutta
per un ospedale di riabilitazione anche
se nel mio caso più che riabilitazione
era luogo dove avrei imparato a fare di
nove di nuovo tutte le cose considerate
più banali ma che in quel momento per me
governo più perché non erano io non ero
autonomo in nulla
io sono sempre stato un ragazzo molto
timido e che non voleva mai chiedere
nessuno e trovarmi in quelle condizioni
in cui infermiere dovevano lavarmi
spostarmi devono accudirmi per ogni cosa
ecco mi faceva morire dentro morire
dentro ogni giorno un motivo per cui mi
impegnai il più possibile da subito per
riconquistare la mia autonomia e mi
ricordo che i primi esercizi per
rinforzare la parte del corpo che mi
restava furono le alzate delle
bottigliette d'acqua da mezzo litro
ancora disteso a letto oppure il
semplice di restare seduto per 5 10
minuti senza senza svenire
lo step successivo fu la palestra ogni
giorno sempre per rafforzare gli altri
superiori ma anche per per l'equilibrio
perché avere una visione alta non avevo
nel controllo del troncone degli
addominali né né nelle dorsali ecco e
poi c'era la parte anche della
fisioterapia occupazionale che
consisteva nel insegniamo a fare quelle
piccole cose come il lavarmi il vestirmi
da seduto perché a con tutte queste cose
dai seduto non veniva così naturale e in
senti istintivo e loro mi segnavano del
insegnato dei piccoli trucchi per farlo
in modo più veloce e con e con meno
fatica e pian piano vedere riuscire a
fare tutte queste piccole cose erano
tutti dei piccoli traguardi e piccoli
obiettivi che stavo che stavo
raggiungendo poi c'era anche tutta la
parte per come si apre come affrontare
gli ostacoli piccoli gradini e discese
come risolvere in carrozzina
quando si cade e quella era un po la
parte che più troverete mia mi ha
divertito e mi è venuta benvenuta più
facile il mio percorso gervasutta è
durato sette mesi 0 risulta è un posto
che mi ha lasciato dentro tanto perché
era un luogo dove la gente aveva
sospetto tanto c'era chi si era visto
portare via un braccio una gamba
pochi magari potevo muovere soltanto la
testa però mi ha insegnato molto il
valore e l'importanza delle ironia
perché lì dentro ogni molti ogni momento
era buono per il 3 su sulle disgrazie
che c'erano e c'erano successo fin
quando è arrivato il momento del ritorno
a casa
sono tornato a casa entrato a casa dallo
stesso cancello dove mesi prima era
uscito in sella alla mia moto ci sono
rientrato sì ma sopra sempre delle ruote
ma quelle della mia carrozzina
una volta a casa avevo di nuovo tutto
avevo i miei spazi
vedevo i miei campi davanti casa dove
andava prix moto avevo i miei motorini
avevo la moto
la moto era lì che mi aspettava però io
non riuscivo né salirci né accenderla ne
ne potevo andarci a correre ero lì
impotente davanti a lei il periodo del
rientro è stato molto molto brutto
perché ero a casa mentre vedevo che
c'erano i miei amici in giro a
divertirsi
certo venivano a trovarmi a casa però il
vedersi a casa non era come vedersi in
giro a far chissà che cavolata insieme
quell'ora periodo delle festività c'era
natale capodanno vicino e mi ricordo che
quello fu il primo capodanno che passai
a casa a casa solo c'era c'erano i miei
libero a 15 anni non era proprio quello
che un quindicenne voleva ecco in quel
periodo lì ho dovuto salvarmi da solo e
per farlo ho capito che avrei comunque
trovato dovuto comunque trovare il modo
per fare le cose che più che più mi
piacevano e così e così ho fatto
ho trovato il modo
di organizzarle le nuove giornate in
base alle nuove esigenze perché far le
cose da seduto
portavano via molto molto più tempo
ho trovato il modo di tornare a correre
amici per le strade e per il paese non
più in sala una moto ma sopra un quad ho
trovato la forza per tornare a scuola e
rivedere tutti i miei vecchi compagni ho
trovato una nuova ragazza con cui ho
ricominciato a fare un sacco di cose
come andare al mare andare a fare le
passeggiate andare in montagna o anche
semplicemente andare al cinema in giro
per i centri commerciali dove c'era un
sacco di gente
ecco io non mi sono mai vergognato della
mia condizione però ecco quando magari
ti trovi in luoghi affollati ci sono
sempre gli sguardi delle persone che
dicono magari lo guarda poverino
ecco però stando assieme una bella
ragazza è come lo faceva pesare di meno
mi sentivo un po più più tranquillo ho
trovato il modo comunque di far la
patente
ho trovato in modo addirittura di
scendere in pista e gareggiare non
corona moto ma con un go kart è
gareggiato addirittura contro persone
che le gambe ce l'avevano e sono
riuscito anche a star davanti a
apparecchi apparecchi di questi ho
trovato il modo di essere di nuovo
felice assieme la felicità avevo
raggiunto il mio obiettivo che mi ero
imposto quello di tornare a una vita
normale dove non erano più i problemi
legati alla disabilità quelli da
risolvere ma quelli di tutti i giorni
pian piano avevo ricostruito quel
castello di carte che era crollato però
mancava ancora un pezzettino e con
questo pezzettino mancante sarei tornato
sulla mia vecchia strada
[Musica]
quello che avete appena visto è quello
che faccio oggi oggi da disabile ho
realizzato il sogno di quel ragazzino di
15 anni ma dietro a questo a tutto
questo c'è stato e c'è ancora tanto
tanto lavoro tanti sacrifici e tanto
impegno e perché no che qualche rottura
rotture di scatole ma soprattutto ci
sono tante persone perché io da solo non
riuscirei a gestire in una situazione la
moto non riuscire a salirci non
riuscirei a spostarla non riuscirei a
rialzarmi quando cade a terra in pista e
questa è la cosa che un po più mi
spaventava nello scegliere di ritornare
in moto era il bisogno costante degli
altri per fare la cosa che più che più
mi piace ma tutto questo bisogno degli
altri è fatto capire proprio
l'importanza nel dare e darsi una mano
che prima che prima non avevo prima
andava in moto solo per me e sono
convinto che ognuno di noi può fare
qualcosa per gli altri anche nelle
piccole cose perché anche se non ce lo
teniamo conto
a volte basta veramente poco per far
felici per far felici le altre persone
mi viene in mente un esempio adesso
all'inizio quando facevamo le prime
uscite in pista
io ringraziavo di continuo tutti per
ogni piccola cosa che facevano per far
proprio per farmi riuscire andare in
moto come anche semplice scaricarla e
gli altri mi rispondevano e boom
ma cosa cosa mi costa però per me senza
quel cosa mi costa non sarei riuscito a
fare la cosa che più mi piace
ecco insieme a tutte queste persone sono
nati i miei nuovi obiettivi il primo è
quello di diventare un atleta
professionista il tris thai motocross da
appunto da disabile e di fare backflip
il backflip per fare consiste nel fare
giro della morte in rampa con la moto è
un obiettivo difficile ambizioso
però io ci credo e ci crediamo e ci
crediamo
il secondo è proprio quello di far
conoscere il mio progetto per farlo
arrivare a più ragazzi possibili nelle
che sono magari ne line nelle mie stesse
condizioni per proprio per prevedere che
si può tornare a fare quello che si
faceva prima e non per forza dopo un
trauma un incidente anche le tue
passioni devono devono cambiare perché
quando ero all'ospedale mi aveva
proposto di fare basket in carrozzina
tennis in carrozzina giocare a ping pong
io li ho provati tutti questi sport però
sentivo che mancava qualcosa
oggi vi ho raccontato la mia storia
anche se magari dovevo parlarvi di più
della della moto dei progetti e dei miei
obiettivi
ma secondo me c'è una cosa ancora più
importante di raggiungere il nostro
traguardo
il nostro gol ed è il nostro il nostro
percorso
il mio percorso mia mi ha insegnato
tanto mi ha insegnato che non attimo
tutto tutto si può perdere ma insegnato
che proprio dai momenti più bui e tristi
a volte si può tirare fuori la forza che
non si pensava di avere insegnato
l'importanza del tempo in questo tempo
di fare le cose che più ci che ci
rendono felici mia mi ha fatto conoscere
persone speciali senza le quali
sicuramente non sarei dove dove mi trovo
oggi ma soprattutto mi ha fatto capire
che la nostra la nostra vita è come un
castello di carte
possiamo impegnarci e più il più
possibile per costruirlo grande e forte
e bello sostenuto da certezze e
sicurezze ma che in un attimo può essere
spazzato via
ma si può però scegliere di ricostruirlo
ancora più grande e bello di quanto lo
fosse una volta e dipende tutto da noi
[Applauso]